this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
it's monday
may the 2nd it's a whole new month and a
whole new set of [ __ ] rules the
joint is brought to you by blue chew
listen don't feel blue blue get blue
chew listen to me blue chew is the best
even if you don't have ed you can take
it anytime day and night and you want to
always be ready you can take it on an
empty stomach it's nice and easy she
won't know nothing it comes to your
house
it tastes like grape candy you drink
some water and 20 minutes later you feel
an eruption between your legs that's
blue chew the process is simple you sign
up at bluetooth.com
and talk to one of their licensed
medical providers once you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days the best part
it's all online no doctor's office no
pharmacy no judgment it ships right to
your door and a discreet package
way cheaper than the pharmacy so if you
could benefit from a little extra
confidence when it's time to perform
blue chew can help and they got a
special deal for the joint family you
ready for this today monday try blue
chew for free listen to me it's may 2nd
you want to get these in the mail
because the summer's three weeks away
and you want to sling dick on the beach
you understand me you get blue chew for
free when you use promo code joey at
checkout just pay five dollars for
shipping that's bluetooth.com
promo code joey they receive your first
month gratis on the arm
on the dick how's that for you
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and i want
to thank bluechu for sponsoring the
joint the joint is also brought to you
by my favorite
it's important to stay hydrated with
liquid iv
one stick of liquid iv and 16 ounces of
water hydrates you two times faster
and efficiently than water alone liquid
iv comes in tremendous flavors like
watermelon lemon lime strawberry pina
colada i like the grape i like the acai
i like the better oh my god they're
tremendous contains five essential
vitamins b3 b5 b6 b12 be nice and
vitamin c
non-gmo and free from gluten dairy and
soy
liquid iv is on a mission to change the
world and they've donated over 20
million servings globally listen since i
had covered i started drinking liquid iv
and i have not stopped
it comes
in bulk and nationwide at costco but i'm
going to do this for you
i'm going to save you 25 off when you go
to liquidive.com use promo code joey
j-o-e-y at checkout that's anything you
order when you use promo code joey
j-o-e-y
at
liquidity.com experience better
hydration today at
liquidity.com
use promo code joey the joint is also
brought to you by
stamps.com listen if you got a small
business inflation isn't doing you any
favors right now you're looking for a
way to cut costs i don't blame you
mailing and shipping is a great place to
start use stamps.com to mail and ship
and to get access to exclusive discounts
and great rates on shipping from usps
and ups it's an easy way to keep more
money in your bucket man how easy is
stamps.com it's easy stamps.com gives
you access to all the post office and
ups shipping services you need right
from your computer listen to me me and
my wife at stamp.com for about 12 years
now between the t-shirts this that
sweaters
it works all you need is a regular
computer and printer no special supplies
or equipment you'll be up and running in
minutes printing official postage for
any letter any package anywhere you want
to send it so start mailing and shipping
with stamps.com keep more money in your
pocket every day
sign up with promo code joey j-o-e-y for
a digital special offer that includes
four-week trial plus free postage and
digital scale
no long-term commitments or contracts so
do me a favor go to stamps.com right now
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and enter codejoey that
stamps.com
code joey time to get this party started
it's a monday morning
we got a guest this morning in-house
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
welcome to the joint it's another
fun-filled week and another fun-filled
[ __ ] month it's made a [ __ ]
second we got a whole new set of rules
and a whole new set of [ __ ]
i don't know what anyway we got my main
man here lisatti came in
for my uh daughter's uh
first communion first communion [ __ ]
tremendous i had him in the church
the first jew ever to walk in the
[ __ ] church
in uh
madawan new jersey [ __ ] tremendous
and you walked in and you got the the
holy water and i was like i don't think
i'm supposed to touch that
jacket look at the back of your jacket
it's like a burn mark back there
like when they threw the [ __ ] holy
water at the exorcist that's
but it was great you know uh it was
great it's really crazy how you see your
kids like you you see anybody your
nephews
and you see them and it's okay
you can't really tell what's going on
take a picture of them and then look at
the picture and you're like
what the [ __ ]
so my day started
you know saturday morning
lee was already here we do an edible
friday night a little bit the delta
eight like a mini one yeah we did like a
mini one for the walmart well and i'll
say this i don't know what you did
before i got here you might you might
have done a full edible
but no i didn't do one
i probably did
i probably did 1400 milligrams that
night and then my wife came down with 15
milligrams and i said [ __ ] it
what's the difference at this point 15 2
000. what's the difference so i popped
that
and dog i slept like a baby i slept like
a baby both nights
saturday night i threw down
sixteen hundred milligrams no no no i
ate seven
and then like i wasn't feeling it i
wasn't feeling 1200 1400 milligrams of
abx
so i took three more they didn't wasn't
did he really put them in my hand oh
and i went i took
lee to my buddy's house
and the [ __ ] had pizzas but he
took out some bagels from staten island
dropping another way
you've seen jersey bagels wait do you
see staten island
oh my god and there were kinds i never
even heard of before i think it was like
an egg everything bageling
i don't even know they made that jeez
and and the thing is so we were it was
i i don't know about you i was [ __ ] up
i'll say that i was already like i was
giggling and [ __ ] you know like
the 1400 was hitting me but it wasn't
taking me to where the promised land and
so when i got over the steve's
i said [ __ ] it and i went in my pocket
and i had three of them in my pocket
and i took the slice of pizza and i
didn't even eat them with water
i took the slice of pizza and i was
talking to lee and i just went
and i dropped and i and then i want my
hand in my pocket and two minutes later
i realized what i had done
and i said to lee i'm gonna die and he
goes what happened that one in my pocket
that was one out of three so that means
i ate two
so i ended up eating nine last night
eighteen hundred milligrams now we got
back
oh
then we got back and we [ __ ] steam
clean
the freeze pipe steam cleaned it boiled
it
the whole thing
i just really want no problems you know
what i'm saying like you just wanna [ __ ]
when you have people over you want it
he's a good host
i steamed that [ __ ] i took the
freeze pipe out i steamed it in hot
water it was liquidy in there that's how
[ __ ] and i refroze it from scratch
and i put in some
maven i mean i love my gaff laughing gas
but when it comes to the ice cream shop
they got great weed across the board
i had a little piece of maven and i put
it in there cherry something 35
i made three bong hits for each of us
but i put a keith layer
like that jello from the 80s that used
to have like you you put in the
refrigerator on a slant so you get
slanted then you fill the whipped cream
and people go oh my god you're a genius
no you just put the glass on the slant
you [ __ ] [ __ ] and it goes to the
side what the [ __ ] is wrong with you you
know what i'm saying
so
we [ __ ] uh i we did that we did three
of them
and lee was [ __ ] up it took me to a
different place but my brother george oh
he took a big hit and he and i cleaned
out the thing and he went by mistake and
you could see his eyes it was like i
stabbed him in the stomach you could see
his eyes like the panic it was like
training day when the guy shot him with
a shotgun and sitting in the chair and i
had to go breathe breathe because
because i i learned
before the church even started
i went to his house and
he had an office way before mercy was
even born he had this little mini bong
and he would put ice cubes in and it was
like first
like
yeah like
we had met and then like a month later
i because we were talking about social
media yesterday the one of the first
time i went everyone to your house you
brought me to your office and i had i
taught you how to put a picture up on
twitter on the computer not even the
phone and he called him an unadulterated
genius because he had no idea how to
even put a picture up and he had this
little bong
i i know and
and he had this little bong and we take
little hits and like i was brand new
i barely ever smoked before but i
started i got a little cocky with with
his weed and then one day you put hash
in and covered it up and i took a big
weed hit i turned as red as that right
on that thing right there
his wife thought i was gonna have to go
to the hospital they brought me to
barbecue
or fried chicken i was still coughing i
cough that's how i started getting
bronchitis because i coughed so much off
of that one hit and that was george
george sat down for like 20 minutes he
was caught he didn't know where he was
he was trying to cover it up he didn't
know where he was and then he left
right and i'm like let's get out of
hilly and finally i go i look at the bar
and i'm like
i see this big phone at the bar and i go
that's george's [ __ ] phone
i go this [ __ ] forgot i can't
even call him you know you can't have
women do send smoke signals
so finally
we're doing something like let's get the
[ __ ] out of here because i don't know if
he's going to come i look at the phone
and i hear banging on the back door it's
i go that's george he's like man i
didn't even know so this morning i
called him i go how was it he's like man
all i know is i'm happy your wife gave
me the meatballs
because when i got home i was we gave
them 25 milligram abx the sleepy ones
no he only had a 25 no he only had 25
but the 25 sleepy abx
is a little [ __ ] deceiving
it's deceiver the 25 is a little
deceiving it takes his time and you're
like oh i beat this i'm fine joey don't
know what he's talking about you know
what i'm saying then you settled
like once you you know when you get
kicked in legs on mma it's so you don't
settle okay once you settle you're like
wow this took me to the promise so he
said when he got home he was fine he
changed into his pajamas and he was
after he sat down the room started
spinning it started turning purple in
there he started hearing people speak in
spanish and he goes that guy
your wife gave me those meatballs
because i hate two of them
and they took him down and then he goes
i'll never smoke out of that [ __ ]
freeze pipe again which is that's the
truth
pipe's fault it's a thirty percent well
people always
always want to blame the least [ __ ]
you know a guy jumps out of a window
with a [ __ ] towel on
and they they they go through his house
he smoked pot well let's blame the
reefer let's blame the guy he was
[ __ ] [ __ ] before he jumped out
the window the [ __ ] reefer just
helped him a little bit to get the
[ __ ] air behind him to [ __ ]
that's it but don't blame the reefer
[ __ ] you know don't blame the
freeze pipe blame your [ __ ] mental
weakness for [ __ ] getting that eye
that's why i tell you always got to
prepare for war what if the iranians
kidnap you and that's the torture yeah
but in this case you're the iranians
you're the one putting the hash in the
window
i'm getting you ready for the [ __ ]
you know for the great when the russians
come and they make you smoke a bomb
they're gonna sit you down and [ __ ]
slap you with their dicks and make it
drink vodka i will not be prepared you
know what i'm saying i will be sucking
russian dick because i don't drink vodka
but if they whip up that bong i'm
winning that [ __ ] race you understand
me and i'm walking out of there laughing
at all you [ __ ] coughing
you're gonna die you're on the next
flight to ukraine what i'm saying
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you i ain't going out like that so
you got to get ready for training today
cox it's like what if the arabs come and
they give you edibles i'm 17 and i'm
looking at them with the 17 and they
start looking back at me going that's
halal that's how i that's a lie this
[ __ ] didn't kill him i walk out of
there floating
[ __ ] with hummus sandals on you know
what i'm saying you'll be [ __ ] up if
they break out the hummus
what if they break out everything
you ate that hummus dog
your birthday video that was the last
time i had hummus i
terrible
i tried to tell you years ago it's a
waste of time it's how they [ __ ]
whining
that's how they indoctrinate you
next thing you know you're [ __ ]
walking around with your hands up and
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying it's like
going to the 7-eleven in north hollywood
by laurel canyon every time you went in
there those [ __ ] attendants will give
you those [ __ ] islam eyes like
between 15 minutes you'll be getting out
of there looking for a pipe bomb and
[ __ ]
you want to target tonight you're taking
off the [ __ ]
the pressure cooker
the pressure cooker department it's the
truth bro he'll tell you about north
hollywood that was a joke amongst us but
it wasn't a [ __ ] joke and it became
not a joke when they actually killed the
owner then people started hitting me up
going joey you're on to something how
did you know go in there
they don't like americans the [ __ ] you
know when you buy a car and then you
suddenly start seeing that car
everywhere yeah or you start look that
was it you told us you're like go in
there you're like they play the music
and then you couldn't i couldn't not see
it you'd go in i don't know what radio
station they were playing but it wasn't
it was it wasn't eighty is on eight it
was a provocative because all the other
seven elevens had those same [ __ ]
dudes in them and they listened to like
the 70s on eight you know what i'm
saying like you know sunshine
on my shoulder you walk into the [ __ ]
laurel canyon one door you could tell
and i used to go in there at night to
get like uh the vapor pens after a
podcast right they weren't nice people
at night and the [ __ ] that hung out in
front of there wasn't nice well i was
just gonna say the problem was they had
a 24-hour laundromat and if you're doing
laundry at three i've done that at la a
couple times when you're the first time
i ever did laundry like three in the
morning that ralph's on
um kawaii like it used to be 24 hours
where they they had the cans delivered
like that used to be open 20 i walked in
there and someone got hit in the head
with a liquor bottle la late at night is
a scary place and what about now
oh now i wouldn't
i couldn't imagine even going i hear all
the drama is by where we used to live
anyway all that drama is on that block
magnolia
they shot a guy outside that [ __ ]
diner i would have
left that diner on fire that's the worst
food in the [ __ ] country nice people
though
it's crazy when you [ __ ] look back
that's a scary neighbor that night
that's a very escape scary neighborhood
at night and it's getting scarier
we were talking about it yesterday and
it's like la just attracts
people with issues because they people
think they're going to go there and turn
into something
and
mix that with drugs and mix that with
running out of money it's a scary
like even that diner
i go people would ask me for like to use
phones if i ever hung out like sometimes
you'd go hang out there and i'd be
outside just to write i used to because
they used to let you smoke
on the outside yeah the smoke so there
was nobody in there i was telling
somebody like towards the end like i
would meet people there but it always i
always noticed that every time i went
home i had [ __ ]
flaming ass diarrhea no matter what i
ate cheeseburger deluxe flaming ass
diary all right
we switch it to chicken noodle soup
[ __ ] more diarrhea okay
bacon and eggs [ __ ] diarrhea and then
i started going in and going you know
what let me just get a milkshake
that's milk and ice cream
[ __ ] diarrhea so i'm like that's it
everything in there gives you [ __ ]
diarrhea we can't go in there no more it
was that bad mike it was that [ __ ]
bad and you tried they got you with the
breakfast wasn't bad but the bacon
sucked it was ox meat or some [ __ ]
rabbit meat or something the coffee shop
had the best bacon around yeah i missed
that that [ __ ] breakfast was
i would bring it here and it would hold
its own
the bacon and the mexican potatoes and
the thousand grain [ __ ] toast with
butter in the morning they did a good
job in mariet if i miss any place
i miss that place a lot and george elias
always calls me he's like i just drove
by there salami
always hits me up i just drove you don't
have a place around here they go get
coffee and chill out nothing there's a
starbucks
but there's a smoothie king that you
could drink a smoothie and sit there
they have tables
i just don't know what panera bread is
around here i miss that i need to find a
place
where you could wake up in the morning
and go write a little bit couple jokes
outside your house like it's good for
you just to look outside the window it's
a change of [ __ ] scenery if you read
the art of uh
uh the one by uh the guy that wrote the
exorcist and all the not the exorcist he
wrote like uh
carrie
steven spielberg his stephen king his
book is about like how he sits
yeah on writing it it's how he sits and
how he faces a certain wall he only
listens to ac dc which is rare because i
can't even listen to music when i
[ __ ] try to write anything if not
you're trying to write a joke next you
know you're singing the lyrics and
you're like i ain't the lyrics i wanted
suck i'm trying to write a joke here
but it's really uh i don't have that
here
but that's okay you know for now like
i'm looking forward to the pool open
because there's places there you could
sit outside and it's shady and they got
great [ __ ] sandwiches that dog i
can't tell you
i'm an old man
and i'm looking forward to the pool more
than when i was a kid
i got so much
i had such a good time it was the first
time in a long time i just relaxed it's
like when people say you want to go
fishing and you're like
the [ __ ] am i gonna do fishing you know
fishing isn't about catching fish it's
just about sitting there
and breathing and getting vitamin d and
talking to your grandpa about you know
when he went to world war ii and fought
the nazis you know it's just stupid [ __ ]
and at the end of it you kind of feel
good it's like a therapy session you
know and you're getting better at it
because you i thought about you when i
was in florida because i sat down on the
beach and i had a hard time for like the
first hour because i thought about you
being like what am i supposed to do now
and it took me a little bit to like
relax a little bit because i was just
sitting there with doing nothing
and i thought of you but you like you i
could see you having fun with a coffee
shop but like the my favorite part about
yesterday was like the party was great
the food was great but then when like
you just we just started like relaxing
like your neighbors came over
you have a good setup down here you have
a good group of people and you know what
it's funny how like
things like it they just really worked
out like your house it's in a perfect
location you have like a cool backyard
it's not too big like it's not like
you're gonna have to worry about it no
no because i'm worthless i can't mow a
lawn
i would chop my [ __ ] foot off
i'm like pat riley on that show when he
tried to [ __ ] trim the trees on his
roof and he cut himself on the foot
right that's me so i knew that i
couldn't get like people like want to
get
a there weren't no fixer-uppers in this
neighborhood this wasn't a neighborhood
fixer-upper so i'm just happy about that
you know i think about the future and
i'm like
who's going to paint these walls
you know upstairs you got to use a
ladder to paint those windowsills and
[ __ ] you do i mean listen i can paint
i can mow grass you know i know i know
how to paint but i know how to paint
right like i like [ __ ] putting the
tape
i don't like runs on the wall i'll take
all the
caps off the receptacles or everything
i'll do all that [ __ ] but it's also like
you're just like it just was smart how
like
the backyard's great to like relax in
but then like i was looking at houses in
florida
mansions almost a million dollars like
you could have this house and like be
retired and i don't know what your
payments are but like you didn't go
overboard like this is like a
comfortable house
she showed me 30 houses and i looked at
a house that
first of all it's me my wife and my
daughter
my wife isn't 40 and we're not going to
get a cleaning person to help us
you know so i said forget about the big
house like i i'm not here for the
joneses right i just wanted a
comfortable house for my daughter and my
wife that we would like i looked at a
bunch of houses
some of them when they eight hundred
thousand some of them were 850 and i'm
like we don't need that room no what am
i gonna do airbnb why
you know i could see a four bedroom
house three of us
you know in an office and maybe her
office or a playroom or something like
that
uh
i'm not a handy guy so i knew i couldn't
get something that
needed work that's just not gonna happen
i'm gonna go broke i'm gonna go broke
you know so i took all those things into
consideration
i didn't know how long we were gonna
stay here but by the looks of things if
you have a child in this world right now
then i'm never going to be able to get a
house no so when you look at a house now
you better look at that house and go wow
i'm looking at 30 years from now how's
his house going to look how's his
neighborhood going to look what we need
to do you know because she's never going
to be able to buy a house there's no
listen
nobody
and you really think about it unless
you're just the perfect child
and you go to high school and college
and you come out you marry a high school
sweetheart and all those summers instead
of going to concerts you [ __ ] worked
at pnc and made money and then and
you put away you know how many [ __ ]
25 year olds
can honestly say
they got all their
college
tuitions paid whatever you call it loans
they got all their bills paid and they
got a hundred thousand dollars to put
down on a house you know 50 000 and
furniture 25 year olds almost none like
even like my age okay so what are we
talking about here how many 25 year olds
are actually eligible for a house right
now if we narrow it down come up with a
specific number american in the united
states and go how many 25 year olds
could seriously right now today buy a
house
with good credit
no bills no college tuition
and
50 000 100 000. or 100 000 let's say i
tell you 25 000 is for
furniture and you know a barbecue and
for outdoor furniture and whatever 75
000 is your down payment so 10 percent
of your down payment is what they want
it could be as low as three it could go
up as high as 20. okay so if you you're
putting down
20 uh 10 percent
and it's 75 000 that's a 750 000 house
right
and now you're left with you know
675 000 in debt plus interest plus
depreciation
plus your kids are coming you actually
got married so you're having they're
gonna have a [ __ ] kid yeah so what
other chances unless you're [ __ ]
perfect
okay and then your parents have to leave
you money we all needed a bump
in our lives as a child we all need a
bump is it for some of us it's
we're [ __ ] [ __ ] we need twenty
thousand but for some of us just fifteen
hundred to get us a roommate situation
with a friend and we could start rock
and rolling from there bed right a tv a
microwave good luck good riddance i put
you through college you're on your own
knock
now
how many 30 year olds can i actually say
have enough money to put down in a house
and all their bills are paid
and
now let's narrow that down joey you're
being a little hard okay
30
your loans are paid
and you have 200 000 for down payment
and furniture but your bills you owe
outrageous amounts on your credit card
which a 28 year old
does okay i don't know what you know
unless your parents just
you know like because it's even 30s
young because when when you think about
it i was supposed to be i signed on to
pay my student loans
for 15 years after i graduated so that
would and so that would have been
i should have been paying them off until
like 36 37
and i with kovitz saved me because they
stopped charging interest so i paid them
off
but
you're gonna have most people gonna have
student loans until they're almost 40
and that's like that's if they're being
lucky and yeah like you can save [ __ ]
but then
i was going to ask you like as someone
who went through hard times
if you if you're trying do things
usually just kind of work out in some
sense do you think it might not be like
the biggest house but if do you think
so like stuff will work out eventually
if you like it might not be when you
want it
at the age of 45
even after i overhauled my life
and got clean on cocaine and i was on my
way
i was still
three four five years away from getting
debt free
i never thought i saw the end of that
because i had an outstanding
child support
and it was revolving it was like an
american express card
so even though i'd pay the 635 when i
got the bill it was 20 higher every
[ __ ] week so i never knew i i was
like this is never gonna end and
when you think about it it makes you
want to jump out of window when you
think about your bills and how you're
going to get them
situated in makes you want to jump out
of [ __ ] window
okay that that's the truth that's at any
age i know i felt like [ __ ]
and that's why i took
paying bills so important
you got to pay your bills yeah you got
to pay your bills because that shouldn't
follow you i've seen it i said car sales
and i saw kids
come in when they were 30 and go over
here to buy a car
and guess what they had perfect credit
but when they were on the sorority or
fraternity they didn't pay their water
bill for a year
you can't sell your car
that just chopped up your [ __ ]
interest payment
you know to nine instead of four you
know i'm saying like something like that
so
you know these are all these things that
you come in with
so
i never [ __ ] saw the end of this
i sold the show and they gave me a lump
sum of money
and that took care of some of that [ __ ]
you know over the years when you when
like the joey karate videos i got a deal
so whenever i got a deal i would take a
certain amount and just pay a lump chunk
and i would send it and go why am i
sending that
like i'm never gonna get ahead just
because i paid them off i got 80 other
people at my door you know when you get
divorced and you get separated and you
gotta
spend 150 000 attorney bills i didn't
see the end of that [ __ ]
that that's
for me it's the worst
when stuff and that like it never stops
there's always gonna be a bill like you
finally start getting ahead and then
you blow out a tire like that yeah
that's that's life that's life guys that
[ __ ] piss and that's the worst
because when you blog that every time
you blow out that tie that pushes you
one step circle to jumping off that
bridge
and it takes a lot of [ __ ] like
i don't know like i'll tell you what
happened guys like i went i got i was
okay
even when i went to prison guys i was
okay financially i wasn't secure
i had a couple thousand the bank and
that's what you want to hear you know
two thousand three thousand that's a lot
better after that
you gotta assume you gotta to take the
troop from 92
to maybe 2004 there wasn't even a bank
account that's crazy okay that wasn't
even a bank account you're a comic
you're a [ __ ] rogue
i was a rogue you know i didn't know
what tomorrow was gonna bring all i knew
was i was getting 125 tonight
and i had to pay child support and i
knew i want to [ __ ] the bartender so i
got to have a grandma coke to do that
yeah that's it
that's where your mind goes guys and and
then you i don't know but i never saw
myself getting out of debt but i did
every time i got something
i paid something you got to remember i
owed 100 grand to easy on attorney bills
[ __ ] from the divorce that's easy and i
paid every dime guys you look at my
credit
every time i paid
to the tea and i didn't have to to the t
i just it was something that i if i was
gonna be a piece of [ __ ] in my life at
least i was gonna have a good name for
paying my bills that's the least you
could do joe just cause one part of your
life is shitty at least what other part
of your life could be decent that's why
i paid my bills
but
since we're on the subject
when i left boulder colorado june 29th
1995 8 95 honestly i was looking at a
quarter of a million debt
and that's if you look at everything
cocaine debt you know the 20 year old at
the gas station the 50 tab at the
chinese place you know when you look at
that quarter of a million all my
attorney bills i took all those credit
cards and wore them out that's what you
do when you get divorced what are you
gonna do
once you once you can't pay those bills
you might as well keep buying [ __ ]
until they until you go to that place
and they're like uh
decline call then that's when you know
time to use the next one
you put that in the back burner you're
going back to the safe to get the other
three that are in there you know i kept
doing that
i got into comedy you don't want to work
it's not a hip thing to work you want to
get together with your comic buddies in
the afternoon and smoke dope and write
stupid jokes
but when i got the taco bell commercial
that's the first time i sat down and add
up exactly at that point
in
august of 98
in august of 98 the bill between us went
from 250 to 150 because those are like
the ones i didn't really have to pay
like that thirteen hundred dollar drug
dealer yeah those don't go on your
credit report the one discover card that
said we already sent you to
whatever like if you called me and you
said we had a problem and i go what's
the minimum payment send me 38 i would
send you the 38
but if you call me back and you said you
sent me the collection i'd rip it up go
[ __ ] your mother now now you're not
getting
so that's another one down so i tried to
do good with these people then i was
gonna join that service that you go
through and they pay your bills off
they'll say you need twenty eight
hundred a month you give me debt
consolidation i tried that and i failed
at that and i was like
i'm just hiding so a friend of mine just
goes just drop off the radar and just
pay cash
just drop off the radar in eight years
your credit will come back and sure
enough
but i did pay off the attorneys
i did pay like i had two attorneys i
owed money to i did pay off my child
support and then the
kicker was at the end
because when you're snorting coke
like it's great because you'll pay
everything oh i owe mike 20 here michael
i don't know what i'm going to need that
20 back you know you pay everything back
but once you stop snowing coke i had to
send six
636 dollars a month for six years
damn
that was a heavy [ __ ] loan guys
that was heavy 636 335 for child support
700 for rent i still remember and i used
to look at that number every month ago
oh am i gonna [ __ ] do it i'm getting
fifteen dollar sets
yeah he's getting fifteen dollars a set
ballet
but man you just put your head down and
then after i stopped doing the coke then
i was taking care of the big chunks
the longest yard in 2004 i was snorting
big coke you know that's what i was
doing 60 of my money but the other money
every week i would have a list of who
terry was gonna pay you know a thousand
to this attorney and i can't tell how
many people said to me like there was
two guys i said to me hey man don't send
me any more money we're good
you did a great job nobody sends you
money 10 years later
you stuck to your word thank you but i
would have never got out of my holes
without
the joy karate deal the fox deal you
know like those big because that's what
what you need you need a 250
listen a 600 a week job is only going to
get you out of a little bit of debt 150
a week maybe
600 cash a week is 2400
between rent food restaurant your gym
your jiu jitsu i'm sure you could
squander it down to maybe
1800 and then
you got 600 to either put away or pay
bills with
so i could put away
3 600 a year and i could also pay off
3600 a year in bills
but that's means i'm not charging
nothing i'm not paying for boots
you know i'm not getting the flat yeah
i'm not getting hit none other than the
supermarket and i got to pay for that
you know i still remember you know
having
two flats on my car
because one flat we could always put two
credit cards together try the visa
discover and call grand model in your
third you know when you get two flats in
one day because you ran over a bottle
that's 600 on a car
unless you go to the mexicans on silver
lake and you get them to give you like
two different tyres
i did that for all you [ __ ]
that i if you use a smaller tire it'll
align tell that to the [ __ ] marines
because i did it for years and you know
that 300 mile tire when you get a flat
the the donut yeah what's the name of
that don't they isn't it called the door
yeah they call donut but they give it
another name too like a 2 000
yeah but no another name
they have a mileage rating for it oh
okay like it's a 500 500 mile spare
tell that dumbledore for two years i did
it for two years the car was driving i
would go down
and i'm on a [ __ ] angle because i got
a bicycle tire i use that thought you
know when you're broke you you figure
out all this [ __ ] that lies
like you know like people say well our
iphone only works for a little while you
know after a while the thing switches
and you have to bring it back in [ __ ]
you get a struggling comic he'll fix
that iphone yeah you'll see that iphone
with a string and a can too yeah none of
the apps will work because
it'll work because we'll make it work
dog i remember driving a car all over
the country that had a [ __ ] hole in
the radiator i drove around with those
things with the pellets that you throw
in and it glues it up
the guy's like you can only do it twice
and then you'll need a new radiator uh
i did like 80 times based on that
radiator finally just blew up one day i
was driving that [ __ ] was on
fire as i was driving
you have no idea you have no idea the
[ __ ] rules i broke that people said
you could never do all that
you'll never make it to colorado on that
tire watch me dog wasn't that the car
that the exhaust would go into the car
when you were driving yes towards the
end and then
the [ __ ] took
that car i paid
600 800 for that car
that car probably
put you know and
had a hundred dollars a show yeah
probably put ten thousand in my pocket
that car that car
that car i hit a car one night
dawg i was headed to the seattle comedy
competition the semi-finals and there's
a guy in front of me
i don't know how this happened i'm
behind them now there's a light drizzle
in seattle it's always a light drizzle
and i'm waiting for the contest i got to
be there by calling late i'm late for
the [ __ ] contest i'm doing like 90
and also i hit that ramp and i'm like
flying and the light turned green why is
this [ __ ] guy going he's like wait
man so i just went to put the brake on
that car went right
when
when i got out he still had the sticker
on it was a brand new [ __ ] car it was
a friday night he was bringing it home
to go show it to his girlfriend and i
just [ __ ] up his back i'm like dog
he's got an insurance card i don't have
it on me but i'll call you tonight would
you give me a number he's like okay
he just took the car okay call me later
bye peel
dawg i never heard a thing from that
like the cop never called me i never got
a letter from insurance i didn't have
insurance at the time i didn't have a
license
i had nothing when i hit that guy that
car wasn't registered he just let me off
the hook
and i went over and took fifth place
that night i could never believe it i'm
like they're like when i got that was
all discombobulated like joey what's the
matter i just rear-ended the [ __ ]
i almost put it through the windshield
with a new [ __ ] car
jesus
it's uh it's really weird when you're
young and you
you know you rack up those credit cards
because you don't it's it's easy to go
to a restaurant and take your girl
and drop 80. yeah get the cheesecake
yeah get the [ __ ] shot
and when that bill comes in the mail you
only made 400 a week and you got to pay
80 and then you start with those minimum
payments well it says you could pay me
80.
you could pay me 19. once you once you
pay the 19
then you're going into the [ __ ] hell
of destruction
bankruptcy
and it's
we talked a lot on the church about like
if college was worth it this and that i
moved to l.a a week after graduating
college i never once stayed at home i
didn't have roommates i didn't want them
now like what saved me over the last two
years was living with my parents having
no
um
whatever it's called no rent
unemployment and i was lucky enough i
got to save a little bit of money
that if i was 21 if i graduated college
now
live at home for four or five years have
no rent and that that's the only way
you're gonna be able to buy that house
because
if you're living anywhere
your
rents probably close to a thousand
dollars
at a minimum and that's if with worm
maids not a great place if you're in la
or new york
that rents a lot higher so if
that's the only way people could save
money now staying at home like if if you
had a kid and they stayed home until
they're 25 that's the only way they're
going to tell them
forever guys don't leave your parents
it's not worth it
if the [ __ ] don't want to marry you
cause you're your parents get rid of
that [ __ ]
you're marrying a woman that doesn't
mind living in the basement
she's not looking for bigger things out
of life
she's looking for laundry being done on
time because she's going to slip it up
and [ __ ] it up
and the meals are not you know when you
get married you got to marry this new
chick and she know how to [ __ ] cook
you got to go through it and then your
mom has to give her a recipe just stay
with mom i'm saving you
so much aggravation
your dreams and aspirations you can do
them
at the basement living with mom
don't leave mom guys you know you asked
me a good question
and it's funny because somebody was
talking about on one of those [ __ ]
serious business shows the other day
i always leaned going to college because
i wanted to go to college i thought that
it was
the best thing you could do as an
american that's what you're supposed to
do is go to [ __ ] college and be
somebody right
that's my personal preference
but can you get somewhere
without college today which just
yeah
i tell you what i don't even know why
these kids go to high school
i don't even know these kids go because
high school is not going to teach you
what's missing from society today
and that's hustle that's a kid saying to
you hey mom i don't want to play on the
computer today we got to figure
something out because i got to make
money i got to deliver a paper there's
no newspapers well let's write our own
nobody's coming up with hustle and that
i can't teach you so why are you in this
[ __ ] school
why are you in this school yeah the only
hustle is online stuff now it's like the
kids making youtube videos doing twitch
that's really and there's a lot they
have they were talking about yesterday
there's college courses now about being
like a video game player online
it's a major now
and like that you could do that
i have
a hard time saying don't finish high
school because like you kind of yeah you
need a g you need at least
but one was
listen we had this conversation a
thousand times all those jobs you went
in
in [ __ ] interviews they never even
asked you about college oh no another
call yeah dude when was the last time
somebody asked you about high school
than a [ __ ] thing you could just tell
them anything yeah how many dog i had a
friend who died and
sophomore year went to work with his
father his father owned the fruit
company you know what his dad died he
inherited the company he knew everything
about the peach you know he knew
everything about [ __ ] fruit grapes
whatever you know
i wanted people to go to college so they
they get the full experience of life the
sorority the fraternity the sports but
if it's gonna put you into 300 000 to
get that experience forget it i can just
send you to a nick game i could you know
i could just do so many [ __ ] things
to replace so you're not 24 going out
into the world and a minus
i'm making a minus and a big [ __ ]
minus and it's a big minus and it's a
big
mental minus when you owe i mean you
don't even know when you're 24 you don't
even know what 66 thousand dollars is
you really don't until you start working
for it and go that's a lot of fun that's
what i'm making a year my [ __ ]
parents do this [ __ ] you know
it's tough
but right now with all the [ __ ] i see
you know there's kids at home [ __ ]
buying their head purple making a
million dollars a year
you know telling people they're selling
products or whatever it doesn't take
salesmanship you learn from your ball
sack you know hustle
you just get sick and tired of being on
the couch and saying i can't live like
this anymore how much longer you know
i'm not gonna go to
itt tech
you know what i'm saying like that ain't
gonna work they ain't gonna teach you
nothing down there
you know and that's the cup we ever stay
home in the daytime you put tv on that's
what you get itt learn how to cut hair
learn how to [ __ ] be a a doctor's
aide no you're not
people go to college for eight years to
be a doctor's aide you've been sitting
on a couch for three years you gained 80
pounds you've got flabbiness [ __ ]
veins on your legs
you smell like popcorn your neck and
you're gonna go to some course for eight
months and i gotta teach you how to be a
doctor's aide hello
hello you know i mean it's just and a
lot of [ __ ] is just experiencing you
could do so much more just getting a job
today and putting your nose to the
grindstone i still believe in that
it's gonna be corporate and you're not
going to like it there's going to be
rules you can't tell that chick with the
big tits hey let me rub your chat you
know you can't crack those type of jokes
i don't know if you can do that anywhere
i don't think you're supposed to say
that danny girl with the big tits but
don't you know what i'm saying guys you
know you could still do it you could
still grow with a company
yeah if you could go to lowe's
if you go to costco like i i go to
jujitsu with a kid
he's a [ __ ] kid he's been a [ __ ]
costco for 10 years told me since they
graduated high school kid drives up in a
nice [ __ ] car he's got a pretty
girlfriend you know he lives with his
parents
i would go to costco all those companies
that are like that you know chick-fil-a
and you're off on sundays
and if you say [ __ ] the gays hey he
works at chick-fil-a you know what i'm
saying nobody's going to [ __ ] hold
you tonight the chicken's pretty good
the chicken's pretty [ __ ] good
nobody's like that's
[Music]
well they don't tell like and they do
tell you but they really don't like you
watch tv and movies and things look
exciting and they look like life is
gonna be great
the thing about like what i'm learning
about regular life and it sounds crazy
because i'm 30 but i like what we had
for 10 years i got spoiled everyone was
fun it was exciting
it turns out life is like like when
you're doing that nine to five
even if you really love your job it's
every [ __ ] day you get to those two
days off and after a while you're like
wait this is every
this is every day because like even in
college you know i had one year i had
class tuesdays and thursdays every other
every other day was
taking a nap
that's how that's when you take it it's
fun but then when you have like a real
adult life you're like this is it sucks
[ __ ] it sucks
i still remember lee being young and
legal and that sucks and i'm like this
is every day
you get it forever
forever
now a lot of people don't have this
insight and i got to be honest with you
guys i had this insight
by the age of 28 that's what by the age
of 27 i was like
i'm gonna have a tough life
this is going to be very tough for uncle
joey i'm going to have to either be a
bank robber i'm going to get shot
robbing a bank
i i don't know what i was going to do
this is going to be [ __ ] a doozy
and that's why i chose comedy because i
was like if you're gonna listen
when you take it in the ass
if you like it it's not a job
not a job
you know you ever go you ever see
somebody who really enjoys their job
like a guitar attack when you go to a
concert like he's like
[ __ ] like tony naomi's guitar attack
or somebody exciting guitar tech you're
like wow they enjoy their job what can i
do to enjoy myself like that if you look
at the clock twice in an eight hour day
that's not the gate for you
if you really think about it i'm not
here to [ __ ] ruin your party
but think about it if you look at the
clock all [ __ ] day
that's not for you
if you're dying to get the [ __ ] out of
there that's not for you
you know we can do a podcast for 10
hours we enjoy it we can talk [ __ ] we
can bring the bong in here yeah
but a lot of people don't enjoy their
job and that that beats up on you
listen i was a strong kid when i was
roofing i had a great work ethic
and i wanted to be the best guy on that
roof anytime i went into a job as much
of a junkie as i was
i always said i want to be the best
worker in here i want to be a junkie
i want them to say this wouldn't be the
best junkie i can be this motherfucker's
a junkie but this [ __ ]
with the eight hours we have i'll take
more junkies
like that was my
prerogative to be the best
on the job you know and that's a lot of
people don't have that a lot of people
don't have that work ethic and a lot of
people don't have the work ethic to look
and go okay i could work hard like this
today
but do i want like my brother yesterday
mike you know he came up for the baptism
dog he walks 10 000 steps a day now
to the [ __ ] regular american that's
like that's great that's nothing not
when you're 58. six days a week he said
six days a week driving delivery fedex
packages
nobody signed up on this planet
for six days a week and ten thousand
[ __ ] spaces a day you know what i'm
saying but only jesus
jesus wanted to walk every [ __ ] day
he should have drove for [ __ ] fedex
but that and that but it's also
like i can't like if i had if i had
enough money like i would have i could
have seen myself maybe trying stand-up
but i don't want to what you're talking
about being broke like that
that's a different kind of that also i
think that scares a lot of people like
how did that not scare you
because i was a loser
and when you're a loser you're not gonna
make six or seven figures anyway
right so i was in a hole i was a felon i
was a loser and i knew it
i had the balls to look within and go
this is what i got to offer anybody
this is what i got to offer anybody so
it's like somebody was saying the other
day we were talking about we went to a
restaurant a few weeks ago and
we dropped a buck 80 for lunch
it was great to food but it was not
cuban food buck 80 for four people
two appetizers no alcohol
that's a lot of money i could go to
miami i could take it to miami we can
all eat that twice and it's 60 bucks
right you know so
but then my friend said to me i want you
to think about it like
osteria has burger night on monday night
it's 16.95
plus a beer
okay and he he looked at me he goes
that's a [ __ ] deal he goes i went to
some [ __ ] with my kids the other day
and dropped they wanted 30 bucks for the
burger with the fries and everything
what you're paying for food now in a
restaurant
you might as well go eat the best now
if you're gonna go to a diner and pay 21
for a steak
you might as well go to the place down
the corner and pay 35 for the steak
because for the 21 you're gonna get it's
not gonna be good at all it's gonna be
like donkey meat
you stab it it's gonna jump up it's
still alive
so right now at this point in life but
what was your question you were saying
what how did you like how like
how could you tolerate that yeah how
could you tolerate because like you're
saying um there's a quarter million in
debt
i can't imagine waking up being like
okay okay
even if i went and got two [ __ ] jobs
a main job in the daytime and then one
from six to 12 at night right how long
would i be in that debt well for 250
thousand a long [ __ ] time i would
have still been in a 500 year debt and i
wouldn't enjoy what i was doing so i
picked what i love to do yeah you can't
get blood out of a rock i'm calling you
up and i'm going mike i owe you 20 000.
i'm gonna pay you that money i know you
want two thousand a month and that's
great but you ain't guessing
i'm gonna give you fifty dollars a month
before you lose your mind on me and call
me a loser
i didn't have to call you
i could have just stiffed you and fifty
dollars a month is better than nothing
so this is the pay plan i propose to you
i'm gonna pay you instead of till may
i'm going to pay you until may of 2018.
that was the calls i was making
the people that i loved the people that
really i knew worked for their money and
you know
that's what i did because no matter what
i wasn't going to get out of debt
i might as well do what the [ __ ] i want
to do on my terms i'm still going to pay
the bills
they might not be the number you want i
know you're looking for a hundred a
month i'm gonna send you 50. but at
least i'm sending you something i know
this ain't the call you wanted to get
but five years ago i would have told you
to go [ __ ] yourself and there's nothing
you're gonna do to me if i don't pay you
now at least i'm giving you the option
i'm calling you like a man so everybody
appreciated that right off the bat
attorneys everybody like that when i
called them up yeah because most people
probably just hide most people just go
go [ __ ] yourself send me the collections
i didn't do that i'm going to pay you 25
bucks it's not what you want
but it's what i could do and i'm going
to pay it all the way to the end
and i knew that
nothing i was going to do was going to
get me out of this debt
and like it's also
it's tough because i see a lot of people
who get married really young
and like that when you start when you
have a family that you don't have the
i guess luxury of maybe following a
dream and doing that i think that's a
lot of people get get stuck doing that
and it's
it's rough
to feel like you have to do it
and like the other thing is like you
also had no guarantee you were gonna
be a successful comic
i had no guarantees i had no guarantees
of anything but i knew
what was my choice
what was my choices
boulder after 12 bucks you're not gonna
an hour without a high school without a
college education you're not gonna get a
job
so i was always gonna be stuck at 500 a
week [ __ ] and i would have had to get
another job part-time and
selling coke i was never gonna make
money selling coke i was always gonna
break even or lose a little bit
okay you're gonna lose a little bit
so the chinese food delivery you know i
was
i was helping a guy like a guy with lay
tile and i would grab for him and he
would give me 50 bucks have you guys
ever grow out of the tub
no you'd rather get raped
by 20 guys and they all come in your ear
that's how bad it is to [ __ ] groud a
towel your knees hurt because you're on
your knees and you got to pick it up and
i used to grab
he would do them in the daytime and then
give me the addresses
and i would go at night and it would
take me three hours to [ __ ] do a tub
you know i did all those jobs and i said
if i combined them all
didn't eat
lived in a [ __ ] car and i would have
never got out of that debt
when you
and as a young man a young woman you
look at your debt sometimes and you're
gonna look at it
what i did one day was stop thinking
about it because it just got me
depressed
every time i thought about my debt
and the numbers like the algebra like
you owe
two hundred and ten thousand there's 52
weeks in a year and never added up
and never added up so
i took a chance with the comedy i
believed
when i booked the taco bell commercial
all those couple of little
things i always took money out and paid
extra
and i told the people hey i booked the
taco bell commercial and i'm paying you
and they would be [ __ ] ecstatic
really all right so my money's going to
work now now they were looking at us how
was their investment right so it was
kind of nice you know it was a great
feeling
uh there was listen there's no
guarantees of anything but i'm going to
tell you something i thought about the
other day because after you write a book
and you hand it in it's anything when
you go to an audition and hand it in on
the way home you're like [ __ ]
i should have said this if you go up on
stage and you come off [ __ ] i should
have done this if you go on stage to
play a band and you don't do that solo
and you forget it you're like [ __ ] i
should have played that solo there's
always something you could have done
better and after i wrote the book i
realized something i had that situation
with my ex-wife and her
boyfriend when he called me a [ __ ] right
and i had the two felonies and i knew
that if i did anything across the street
or did anything i would go to jail for
25 years that's the you know it's called
the lifetime offender and they throw you
in jail
the day i hit him the day i decided to
hit him was the day i i didn't know but
it was the day i succeeded
when you decided
i was looking at 25 years and i didn't
think about that
and that's a plus
that was a plus because i got away with
that and that that that whole situation
made lifted me up one
i don't like living my life feeling like
i was half smacked and i was walking
around half smacked by that guy so when
i smacked him knowing that i could do 25
years
it's like at the end of the longest yard
the longest yard the original longest
yard
why the original longest show i'd set
you off with burt reynolds is because he
throws the game and he's sitting there
and he's looking at that old man
but reynolds keeps looking at that
[ __ ] old man and i watched that movie
when i was 10
and i thought about that move
the rest of my life
and he looks at him and he goes hey man
come here for a second
he goes when you hit the warden
was it worth the 25 years
and that old man looked at him came a
look and he goes
yeah
it really was
when i was 10 years old that move took
me and spent a night for me that
somebody would be looking at 25 years
and said [ __ ] it
i'm gonna do what i [ __ ] do
regardless of what you want to do to me
and i'm gonna do it and [ __ ] believe
in it
to have the belief never mind just do it
some people say you know uh defunct the
police and some other idiots are like
yeah debunk the police and you know
they're like oh my god what did i say
you can't have that feeling you're going
and you're believing in what the [ __ ]
you're doing so on the way down there i
was like
i'm gonna take his [ __ ] head off my
shoulder his shoulders and i did
i smacked him i i felt good about what i
did
but
that move
put me out there
because i was looking at against the
odds i was looking at a life sentence
there was going to be no comedy there
was going to be no mercy there was going
to be no church of what's happening now
there's going to be no lead
so by doing that bad day
and just going this is what i'm going to
do i'm going to go for it and once i
went into court it's so weird when the
judge says i'm dismissing this i knew i
was leaving time
i knew i would now i really had to go
for comedy because this was a sign from
god that you beat that
now you got to go for comedy and that's
what really happened that stupid
decision i made that day
was the one that
took me to the next level
now what do you think and you're
different because you are very good at
comedy
but
what do you think let's say this let's
say you weren't
at what point do you have to give up on
a dream like do you think that people
should be honest with themselves about
that too like at some point
that's the [ __ ] the hardest thing you
could do is be it's the hardest thing to
look at mike and go mike we're ending
this band
yeah but we're doing great we've been
together four years you know
it's it's it's
i don't know it's just [ __ ] tough
what was it like how do you like if you
were if you were doing comedy and you
were still doing a hundred dollar night
spots do you think you'd still be like
would you be struggling now at all at
your age or what do you quit by now
i would have been struggling
listen i look for a job for two years
there's nothing i could do
that means in other words i would have
been struggling i could have probably
been like a
help somebody deliver papers or
something like that but
at 50
we were talking about this a couple
weeks ago we had a friend
lee was friends
from the comedy store that killed
herself well that's what we think we
haven't gotten the full
she was a very sweet girl you know
and she struggled a lot with comedy it
was very rough for her you know
you know when you get into comedy they
change the rules on you before you get
there like oh yeah lee all you need is
one commercial you're a star then when
lee gets out there it's ten commercials
well you told me one for the longest
time
so
all that [ __ ] is rough and i i ever
since she's passed away i felt really
bad about it i did a podcast about it
that when do you pull the plug
when do you look at yourself and go you
know what
i really wanted to be the next jimmy
page but it's not working out for me
that's
that's rough man
that's a rough day but then you have to
look at your situation are you still
51
living in a basement
by yourself
drinking doing drugs or do you have a
family now do you have to quit for them
do you have to do something different
for your life for them
when is the dream over
right
i don't think the dream is ever over you
just have to take the dream
and condense it to what's going on in
your life now that's what i think
like if
all right let's say i was still
struggling
and me and my wife had mercy and i could
get on right now i could get on cruise
ships
right that's 2 000 a week
that's you know that's not bad money
when you've struggled at 100 a set
i know most comics would like to play
radio city
and you would like to play the improv
but that's not available to you
so are you content with being on a ship
and going when i go on facebook and i
see
thompson girl rather theater or
crystalia
am i gonna be comfortable with that i
started with those guys so it's all
whatever you could and that's a [ __ ]
up thing about like
the entertainment world
is you could be the best
and for some reason
you never took off like it's a lot of
value there's a good chunk of it that's
luck too it's luck
listen the best comics right now are not
dave chappelle
they're not joe rogan they're not
crystalia
they're not joe coy i love those guys
they're my friends they're great
comedians
but there's a [ __ ] white dude that's
on probation right now in nashville
that smokes crack
this guy could do 20 minutes just
talking about his [ __ ] mother
that type of [ __ ] right
those guys are very funny they're just
not like the the best story i could use
is there was a guy when kennison was on
the road
and he walked into a club in chicago and
he saw this guy that i saw a couple of
years ago great guy
i thought the guy was the best working
comic in the country when i saw him he
[ __ ] had me laughing from the
beginning to the end he had a signature
bit
and i once heard that kennison thought
the same thing about the guy like why
didn't that guy ever go to [ __ ] la
well he had six kids and his wife's a
teacher and she's like a principal she
had great insurance and great benefits
so you have those guys you know college
basketball pro basketball
[ __ ]
you know uh kylie irving is great you
know the guy from golden state is great
there's a lot of great players but guess
what
there's a lot of black [ __ ]
that'll take your ass to the hoop
they're blind they're living in philly
they must have shot a guy 10 years ago
they couldn't get into college
or maybe he didn't pass the acts you
know when they had the rucker league in
new york that was that was cool that was
a league that was for guys that were not
going to go to the pros but dr j would
go down and they get the best
competition on saturdays because these
were the best guys the guys you see in
l.a right now i hope they're the best
guys
i hope i'm a good storyteller but i know
in my heart
that there's
a black dude in dc right now that
doesn't even know how funny he is
it's like when you go to
nashville or you go to
knoxville and you see a hot blonde and
you're like
that [ __ ] does not know she lives in
knoxville because obviously she'd be on
a plane to [ __ ] miami
for somebody to give her a million
dollars
she doesn't know when you go to texas
you'll see a blonde and you're like what
the [ __ ] is that
and she's dating that fat [ __ ] dude
yeah what the [ __ ] that girl doesn't
know that she that pussy's worth 10
million dollars
i'm not talking sex i'm talking like
l'oreal like she's that pretty
she doesn't know that she could walk
into la right now and somebody at a
diner is gonna go can i get your card
because
i'm going to put you on a [ __ ]
commercial everybody thinks cindy croft
is beautiful
you know
there's always somewhere somebody that's
better than you or what you do
he may not have the same situations or
the same
whatever that you have but i feel it is
i i feel it
and i've seen it i've gone to comedy
clubs where i've seen a guy and go
[ __ ] that [ __ ] never buff i
hope that [ __ ] never makes it
out of here right i hope his crack deal
never goes to jail you know because that
[ __ ] will be out now like
smoking people
[ __ ] i've seen that too
but that's just it's
it's so cool to like get to see like
that was like the people i got to see
now it's just cool to be around
people
that like
actually live their dream it's it's very
rare very rare you know that's why i had
wolfie in them i mean when we got to l.a
we saw a bunch of people that were
getting there now you see the agostino
yeah he's working yeah the agostino zoid
is dear friend of mine our friend eric
rocha moved up a spot
rachel wolfson wilson just got in a
[ __ ] movie
so you feel very happy for those people
they they're on the when you see
somebody get into the rotation you're
like okay
i'll be seeing them in seven years on
something
i hope they know that and that's why i
remind those people all the time can
condom
you know all those girls when they get a
little bit of success don't give up yet
don't give up that [ __ ] [ __ ] for a
kid
you know hang in there
hang in there because you're six years
away and if you're a guy and this
happens to you don't [ __ ] around because
you're right there netflix just gave you
a special and adam sandler put you in a
movie yeah but i don't sound like what
it used to be i agree
but you're in his movie and if that guy
puts you in the movie that means
somebody else is going to put you in a
movie that means something else going to
put you in the movie if you got into a
movie and you got two lines and 10
movies don't quit
because if you quit you're about to get
put in the whole movie but you're going
to quit because i only get put in two
lines
that's how many people you've been
moving into no you
okay then that what are we [ __ ]
talking about here how hard is it not to
lose your cool and like start like you
think like when you start making it like
when you get that taco bell commercial
was it hard for you not to like turn
into like an la douche bag
no because you have to
outlive
the early
things like it's
it's like when mike is doing his open
mic on mondays and finally he does gets
the right
to solo right from you're all i got
tonight
the car's first down you know like he
had great solos in there
for the last eight weeks you've been
doing that [ __ ] solo and you've been
[ __ ] it up
the week that you get it right and it's
really good like the week you get it
right it's not only right but it's
[ __ ] better than the guys
will you not wake up the next morning
call guns and roses and say hey let me
talk to slash man i got something to
tell listen [ __ ]
last night i did you're all i got
tonight it was better yeah i mean
you know how many times i called like
william morris
after a coke down like after like i did
a great set and then got coked up and
during my coked up my coke. self talked
my stupid self that i'm ready for
william morris so i got it the next
morning opened up the judy carter book
and called william morris and said i
want to talk to one of your top agents
and they're like who's this and i'm like
joey diaz i did 43 minutes last night
and that you haven't heard the last to
me and awesome it's like click
hello hello
hello and i called back and like joey
yeah click okay i was like oh so we all
[ __ ] up it's just better to [ __ ] up at
that level
than to [ __ ] up in l.a like to get a
deal on that lane pull up to the store
with a mercedes and start throwing spits
at people and saying [ __ ] you you're
never gonna make it
no i never could
i always knew i always knew it was luck
i always knew it was love
what's the definition of luck good luck
it's one
preparation um
hard work hard work
i always knew
that
i would get that luck because i knew
that that would pay off
and then it's just not hard work it's
what work you do
it's what you're doing some people get
up you know you need to you need to
[ __ ] uh
write a song
you want to get up and [ __ ] play the
tambourine
that's okay i appreciate you playing the
tambourine
i'm sure [ __ ] uh humble pies getting
back together and they need a tambourine
player or something like that in the
next 10 years
but i needed you to sing right you know
what i'm saying so a lot of people
i i think that i was very lucky but i
always knew that
if you you know i always
like there's always somebody who's gonna
[ __ ] on you bro i got the nero movie
yeah but you only got two lines and you
got shot in the beginning
that you get depressed about that but
then your smart self goes
that [ __ ] has never done nothing
right
that motherfucker's never done nothing
and okay the the movie was a bomb
and okay i only had two lines but you
find something but guess what the guy
did my lines with anthony lempockley
he's a trained actor i'm a fat [ __ ]
that's a junkie
i could barely not snorkel so i did some
do something good so you have to take
the little victories because eventually
the little victories add up and that's
the [ __ ] truth
if you're not satisfied today my
daughter's team lost
uh yesterday and the double had the
first game they lost like 14 to one
she was throwing uh
some girl hit a home run and mercy got a
hit
the girl was throwing she threw 14
strikeouts
and the only two people was the girl
that got the home run and my daughter
got like a little head of a single or
something like that they lost mercy was
upset i found the silver lining
there's a silver lining and everything
even if you get your ass kicked
there's a silver lining it made you
stronger it did something you know so
when i think of all that la stuff it's
just going there with a clear head and
when something good happens
the next day you wake up in the morning
you go yeah i booked the movie with
dinero but guess what i'm still a piece
of [ __ ]
it's time to get back out there and work
because your job is never done it's
monday you bad [ __ ] i want to
thank lee for spending the weekend here
of course uh he made life a lot easier i
was gonna invite mike but mike had a gig
on wednesday on saturday so i felt bad
about that
but uh it's a great week it's a great
month we're back [ __ ] it's monday the
may [ __ ] second we're going into the
summer months
the birds are chirping
the sky is blue and my balls are
tremendous i love you [ __ ] i'll
see you wednesday morning tip top magoo
and now for a word for my [ __ ]
sponsor jack
all right the joint is brought to you by
stamps.com
listen if you got a small business
inflation isn't helping you out you're
looking for a way to cut costs mailing
and shipping
is a way to start use stamps.com to mail
and ship and to get access to exclusive
discounts it's an easy way to keep your
money in your pocket we've been working
my wife and i with stamps.com for about
12 years and we love it
the stamps.com gives you access to all
the post office and ups shipping
services you need right on your computer
like i said all you need is a regular
computer and a printer no special
supplies or equipment you'll be up and
running in minutes
printing postage for any letter any
package anywhere you want to send it so
start mailing and shipping with
stamps.com and keep more money in your
pocket
every day
sign up with promo code joey for a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale
no long-term commitment to contracts go
to stamps.com
click the microphone at the top of the
page and enter code joey and you'll be
ready to rock the joint is also brought
to you by the best
liquid iv oh my god i've been drinking
the grape this week tremendous it's
important to stay dry
hydrated
one stick of liquid iv and 16 ounces of
water will hydrate you better than just
plain efficient water alone liquid iv
comes in great flavors like watermelon
lemon lime pina colada me i'm a grape
i'm a cherry and i'm an acai berry man
this contains five essential vitamins b3
b5 b6 b12 and vitamin c non-gmo and
gluten free
grab liquid iv in bulk at nationwide at
costco it's great it's right there for
you but i'm going to send you i'm going
to save you 25 off when you get go to
liquid
iv.com and use promo code joey at
checkout to deliver it right to your
house you don't need to go to costco and
i'm going to save you 25
and that's what it's all about saving
you get us
i'm going to save you 25 off anything
you order
when you use promo code joey
liquidity.com
get the best hydration available to you
with liquid iv.com
promo code joey the joint is also
brought to you by one of my personal
favorites because if you want a sling
dick you got to use blue chew jack
you can take it any day
anytime day or night and the process is
simple you sign up at bluetooth.com
talk to their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved it's time to
sling dick the best part is it's all
online no doctor's office no pharmacy no
judgment it ships right to your door to
discreet package the mailman won't even
know and bluetooth tablets are made in
the usa listen they're tremendous
i know your dick works fine you're 28 it
should work like a [ __ ]
you know like one of those things you
bang on the floor but
you want to go in there with smoke
coming out of your dick that's why
blue chew can help you so do me a favor
they got a special deal for the joint
listeners try blue chew
for free when you use promo code joey at
checkout just pay a fin for shipping
that's five dollars that's bluechew.com
promo code joey to receive your first
month gratis free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information i want to
thank bluechu for sponsoring the podcast
i want to thank bluechu i want to thank
liquid iv and stamps.com but most
importantly i want to thank you savages
for having my back and lee for coming
down
and you [ __ ] for always being
here i love you i'll see you wednesday
morning
tip top magoo
love a mexican it's cinco de mayo we cut
suckers
you